all right uh it won't take long i'm just
gonna hand the microphone right over to
you chansey go
take take the floor
if you're still there i'm here i'm just
switching to my notes perfect
and then when we do q a do you want to
read do you want to read over the q a
yeah if there is any okay fabulous hi hi
everybody i'm chancey fleet i am the
assistive technology coordinator at new
york public library
my branch is the andrew haskell braille
and talking book library so we're part
of nypl and we're also part of the
library of congress
and i actually joined the library in
as a volunteer because i realized that
we had a need in our community for
people with disabilities mostly blind
folks
to learn technology skills and
confidence from one another because
if you're blind and you go into an
integrated space and you want to know
how to do something even something
simple like use skype
or use social media the people around
you don't know how your magnification
or your screen reader or your voice
control work
so it creates this profound uh illusion
of difficulty
when everyone around you is so unsure of
what your path is and i noticed that
fellow activists of mine in the
disability community we would be headed
down to washington dc
to do some legislative advocacy and we'd
have you know three hours on the amtrak
and we would spend so much of that time
telling each other about our technology
problems and solving them
and swapping advice about what phone to
get what computer tools to use
what to do in an inaccessible class and
we just developed a
real resilience and so we started
what was called the computer support
clinic at that time it's a little dated
now as volunteers
to just pair people up with confident
technology users with disabilities
so that anyone could come to the library
and achieve their technology goal
it went really well um our demand kind
of skyrocketed and i got hired full time
in 2014
away from my other day job and shortly i
was joined by two other
uh former volunteers and these days we
do about 150 to 160 hours of free
peer supported check coaching each month
and then
in 2017 i was
approached by someone who's pretty well
connected in the blind community and all
they wanted was a five borough map
and i thought i have no idea where a
blind person gets a five borough map and
i started to really consider
beyond the immediate needs that we were
meeting in terms of technology support
what was our community missing and one
of the things that our community
was missing was access to the means of
production
to produce tactile graphics and 3d
representations
and so i founded the dimensions lab in
2017 which is a place where people can
come to access skill building
support mentorship workshops and
equipment
to work on making 3d representations and
tactile graphics
some of it folks do cited folks are free
to come into and people
from cultural institutions do and
educators and families do but blind
folks come in as well
and they either work collaboratively
with cited team members
or they work with design using code
or they remediate images that are
already available on the web and so
we started that in 2017 and that's
really still going strong and through
the convergence of these two kind of
projects
access to spatial information and access
to just
technology education in general it's
been my privilege
to work with community partners over the
years especially since around 2016 2017
to help patrons explore introductory
topics
in computer science and that really
involves
a lot of basic technology education and
what to me
are reflexive
good practices for technology education
supporting students who are blind to low
vision
and also access to some spatial
information and
in spatial ways of knowing that are
non-visual so i want to talk about four
initiatives that we've done
since around 2016 and just some of the
things that we did
to make technology education computer
science education
accessible to youth and adults who
were pretty uniformly fairly novice
learners
i chose to focus on novice learners
number one because we're a library we
welcome everybody we're not
huge on doing prerequisites we want to
be a place where people
can come and explore something they
didn't think that they could do and
number two in a lot of ways i'm a novice
learner so i should be working with
novice learners and one of the best
things about
doing these initiatives has been being
able to bring my own practice along and
evolve
in my understanding of computer science
and our third reason for working with
novice learners is that we hope
by providing foundational education in
in a dedicated space will give people
the confidence to go forward and
integrate themselves
into other experiences more advanced
experiences but they really have to have
the fundamental confidence first
so first off we do introductions to
arduino for youth and adults
so as you probably know arduino is a pro
popular micro can
microcontroller um it and its clones are
really beloved in the maker community
there are all sorts of
uh arduinos available for robotics
and wearable devices and iot and all
sorts of things
um natively they're pretty accessible
right they're just small boards with
pins and headers and components
but the pins and headers and components
when they come in the mail are not
labeled in braille they're only labeled
in print and there's a diagram usually
that comes with the device and that too
is a bunch of print so right away one
thing we need to do for
all of our workshops adult and youth we
provide a braille
and electronic reference guide to the
arduino's major components such as the
processor the power supply
the reset the headers and the pins and
we put those
spatially arranged in a textual table so
that people can
use that card as a map as a reference to
the arduino that they're working with in
our case usually it's the arduino uno
although we do have individuals now who
are branching out
um working with arduino means wiring
and typically you know wiring is
accessible the tip of a wire can be used
to count pins on a header once you know
the order
not a problem but wires are typically
kept
straight you know by sighted people by
color so that you know if you're making
a positive or negative connection
so we ask students to just tie a knot
when wiring a positive connection and
that's it that's done that's how we stay
organized so
not a huge innovative practice just a
way of knowing a way of keeping track of
things that's that's alternative
arduino has lots of online documentation
and videos i'd like to shout out the
lady aida tutorials in particular for
being fairly accessible
fairly narrative and friendly but um
most
documentation in the maker community
visual features visual only content so
there might be a video that has portions
of action that don't have any
description
screenshots and slides that are just
visual and not described
and schematics that are largely
inaccessible online
so for our immersions into arduino
whether it's the one hour
for adults the intensive for adults are
for day for youth we provide verbal
instruction
hands-on instruction where we pass
things around and talk about them and
talk about how we can differentiate them
and navigate them
and electronic text instruction that is
free from undescribed materials
for our youth and our adult workshops so
just curating the
instructional materials so that there's
nothing inaccessible
in the mix the arduino ide the
integrated development environment
is largely accessible but if you're a
windows user
requires you to install the java access
bridge
this may not be necessary anymore by the
way for nvda users so if you're thinking
that it's not necessary anymore it may
be right in some cases
but for most of these workshops we've
had to address it
because a lot of folks use jaws and the
nvda
bundle java access bridge is a newer
thing
and it's a doable thing folks but it
involves
making some changes to some java
libraries and using the command line
which can be a little bit intimidating
for most novice
cs folks so our workshop actually
provided laptops already
configured with the ide running and
tested
and students were invited to bring in
their own laptops if they wanted
assistance navigating the process
so that they could use their own laptops
before or after our sessions
in our early arduino workshops for
adults
and for all of our youth workshops we
actually avoided breadboarding and
wiring
almost entirely by using the grove base
shield
that would be grove base shield which
comes with a starter kit of
sensors and inputs
and that fits over the arduino and
provides
plug and play access to custom
components um
with including power communication
everything without the need for
breadboards or soldering it's no harder
than plugging a phone
jack into the wall and this allows
students to focus on coding concepts
and troubleshooting and understanding
inputs and outputs understanding serial
and analog and all that jazz
not spending a lot of time focusing on
wiring we believe that blind people can
and should use wiring and learn about
wiring and breadboarding and soldering
more on that later
but when we have kids or adults for
three hours we have to think about what
our top goal is and if our top goal is
to teach coding and cs concepts
we're not going to spend all that extra
time on wiring
so those grove kits come with sensors
for sound temperature
light among other things a relay servo
motors
buzzers and led lights so students can
use them to build
lots of simple tools such as a light
level indicator or a sound level
indicator
a game show buzzer or a doorbell among
other things
and when we work with students we
emphasize the need to read code
precisely preferably with the braille
display and if they can't read with the
braille display
to set their screen reader's punctuation
level to all and we really
emphasize um interrogating the code
making sure that statements that get
open get closed
etc right away
one of the nice things about arduino is
that there's a library of pre-made
sketches
that are commented out and pretty easy
to read and we show students how to read
and adapt those arduino sketches in the
library to be accessible before they
write their own
code we start out by uh showing them
the the button buzzer test which
typically is an led light that lights up
when you press the button
and we have them alter that so that the
led
output is replaced by a beeping buzzer
output and we have them
um edit the that length in milliseconds
of the output so that's something that
they can do almost right away
while they're still learning to read the
code before they even have to write
their full
first full line of code students are
encouraged to explore the library of
examples that's built into arduino which
is pretty extensive
as well as online projects beyond the
library
and they're introduced to more advanced
topics like the voice recognition and
to speech shields just so they know
what's possible and we hope that
students will begin to think of arduino
as a way to explore physical computing
accessibly
but also a low-cost way to create
custom-made accessibility tools for
themselves
if you do a google for the blind arduino
project we have a blog it hasn't been
updated
in a solid six months but most of the
content's pretty evergreen we teach you
how to make a continuity tester
we teach you how to use the grove base
shield to talk to you about the id
and all that stuff so you can check that
out later
in the evolution of our work with
arduino we started out blind arduino
project with myself
joshua miele and john schimmel from diy
ability
and later in our work with arduino we
worked with more community partners
lauren race and claire kearney volp of
nyu itp
to ascertain the effectiveness of using
tactile graphics to enhance students
ability to work with the arduino and the
breadboards
so using the tip of a wire or stylus
it's relatively easy to traverse and
count headers on the arduino itself or
on the breadboard
but lots of students find the process of
wiring a circuit
really novel and sometimes confusing so
clear and lauren developed some tactile
graphics for the breadboard and
components themselves
and the assembly of a circuit so
students who use tactile graphics to set
up a push button buzzer
generally found these graphics uh
to to be somewhat helpful but many
students also needed textual description
and hands-on instruction as well to
complete their first circuit and
interpret the diagrams
and we believe that's largely some of it
is because the
design needs some iterating but also
because for many of us we do live in
image poverty
we don't experience so many ubiquitous
images from an early age so even when
they become available the task of
interpreting them can be a little bit
more of a tall order for us
moving on the spring right before the
pandemic kit
we did a blind soldering intensive we
ensured that all instructions were
available in accessible formats
we had tactile schematics for the
completion of a continuity tester
courtesy of lauren race you can check
out her work at tactile schematics.com
there's a full flight of graphics for
physical computing
we had teaching assistants from nyu
students and faculty
and a lead instructor who's blind josh
mealy who's an experienced blind maker
we did a few things differently in that
class everybody first practiced with a
cold soldering iron so that they could
get the idea of picking the siren
ironing up taking it to its target
location and then placing it back safely
in the soldering iron
and and priming it uh we
used forceps clamped to a circuit board
to point to a solder site so that the
hot iron could be used like a tiny cane
to trace the forceps to the right
location we loop solder around component
points at the solder site to hold it
steady rather than
feeding solder so that's a more
controlled non-visual approach
and we pointed out things like the smell
of melting solder and the release of
tension when solder melts away and
little tick when it melts away so that
students could observe a complete when a
complete joint was made
non-visually volunteers were trained to
point out potential problems and answer
questions but never ever complete steps
for students not every student completed
the project
which was a continuity tester but
everybody came away from the event with
confidence in basic soldering techniques
and safety
so check out tactileschematics.com
that's a full flight of schematics for
physical computing we just
scratched the surface with our intensive
so two down two to go
we have done a series of 3d printing
workshops with openscad
so openscad is an open source fully
accessible
almost fully accessible way to
make 3d designs using code alone
so a student can code simple geometric
shapes
that are placed on a canvas that can be
rotated translated unified subtracted
and scaled
objects can be also 2d objects can be
extruded at any given height including
standard and braille fonts
and output goes to stl files for
standard 3d printing
our 3d printing curriculum for blind
adults was written by claire kearney
volp
and instruction was supported by lauren
race joshua emily and alexis hugh among
others at the nypl
and the curriculum introduces
fundamentals of fused deposition
modeling and how it creates 3d prints
participants are then invited to
consider the cartesian plane
using pipe cleaners popsicle sticks and
other simple manipulative tools to
really get a picture of the xyz plane
next folks learn about the code
necessary to make spheres
cylinders cones cubes and polygons
how to rotate and translate those things
on the cartesian plane
and how to scale items and how to use
code to subtract one or more shapes from
a parent shape
those are the building blocks that we
need to create a complex 3d design so
finally students are able to create
chess pieces
rings or projects of their own choosing
the biggest accessibility barrier to
using openscad
is that the real-time rendering on
screen is of course only visual
so students have to start printing their
design
or work with an interpreter to detect
any errors in their code as long as that
code successfully compiles it all
recently i have had access to a graffiti
prototype tablet and have been
experimenting with that to explore it on
screen renderings
it's very low res but i think it has
some promise and i'm hoping to introduce
the tool to library patrons when we can
safely return to the branch
in the meantime we're going to be
running an online version of our
openscad course in early december
with the help of three students from the
last cohort
encouraging folks to use 3d printers at
home at school or in community centers
where possible
um finally during this pandemic in
august
through october claire community volp
led a web development class with our
library for blind adults
that met for eight consecutive saturday
sessions the course introduced the
fundamentals of html css
and javascript and provided each student
with the opportunity to create a
personal website to complement the css
section of the course claire and i work
collaboratively to refine tactile
graphics sent to each student
that show a box model the google web
page with and without alignment
the difference between serif and sound
serif fonts and variations among
font families claire also produced a
tactile color wheel that identifies
contrasting colors as well as which
colors are primary versus secondary and
tertiary
students generally found these graphics
helpful although again in some choice
cases they needed
extra time to interpret the graphics
because they're pretty novel and
sometimes express that
they'd also like simpler or additional
graphics each student was paired with a
teaching assistant who was available to
them after class to answer questions and
troubleshoot as they built their
websites
and all students were able to complete
the course and build a site
so i want to bring it all together here
all of these endeavors had a few things
in common
we identified a content area
where some reasonable amount of
accessibility already exists
we weren't like hey let's all let's go
use scratch because scratch doesn't have
significant accessibility
we identified arduino soldering as an
activity
3d design with code and web development
is already having
pretty good native accessibility in each
of these content areas though the
average sighted person or inexperienced
blind student might identify the
activity as difficult or impossible to
do
accessibly because the workflows and
kind of the
best practices for non-visual success
aren't all that discoverable on the web
and not discoverable at all in
integrated settings
in each content area we identified the
barriers to frictionless accessibility
so for arduinos and basics labeling
wire management visual instruction
finicky ide setup
light used as the hello world test and
we replaced those things with something
more accessible
for 3d design we used a text-only
curriculum with well-described code
examples
so you don't see the code example
rendered on screen you better have a
good description
and we also passed out primitives
showing the code at its completion state
we enhanced this with manipulative that
students can use to understand
fundamental concepts like the cartesian
plane
for soldering having a lead instructor
who's blind and documentation that
emphasized effective
non-visual techniques for soldering
safety making connections and monitoring
progress
having tactile schematics and text
descriptions depicting how to complete
the circuit
and that was about it soldering as it
turns out is pretty accessible
for web development we had a text only
curriculum that again
described code examples with rich
effective description
tactile graphics to support css conflict
concepts team members available to
troubleshoot
screen reader issues so team members who
understood about screen
readers and plenty of opportunities for
feedback
so for all four of these endeavors
some things kind of apply to all of them
the library is a small branch with a
small budget
and i'm the technology coordinator and
i'm kind of
the one that interfaces with computer
science education and
i don't know everything that i hope to
know in the future
so because of who i am and because of
what our budget is
we have tremendous goodwill and access
to community and we have great access to
space but
you know not a big budget and not all
the expertise that we need so having
community partnerships to bring
together blind and sighted experts at
the library and around the
coupled with my ability to effectively
recruit lots of diverse blind
and visually impaired students and
assistants
has enabled us to develop some programs
that
aren't available in very many other
places to spark new ideas and
collaborations through our diversified
teams
and to bring along students who are now
able to function as assistants
and volunteers and pay it forward and
and democratize the knowledge that we
have
again for all four of these endeavors it
was really important to train
our volunteer tas and assistants to help
them avoid over-helping
students to understand and respect
non-visual workflows
and low vision workflows and understand
a little bit about disability culture
and for our students we needed to create
an environment where non-visual
techniques were taught and believed in
high expectations for blind students
were the norm and students completed
every step of the process without ever
being told that part of a task is too
visual
we hope that we prepare our youth and
adult students to go in
into integrated computer science and
stem settings with confidence in some
basic techniques
so that if they are met with uncertainty
and pushback about their participation
in a cs course or cs activity which
honestly
they usually will be they can move that
conversation to one about capacity
solutions and workflows rather than just
take exclusion from cs
and stem activities for granted that's
all i've got thank you
thank you very much chancey um what a
great program
um we're gonna we have some questions
for you but we're gonna pause and let
the interpreters switch over
um so uh everyone can take a minute or
so to
stretch their legs and catch their
breath after hearing
all about chansey's inspiring amazing
program there in new york